mittlerweile sind einige Rapper auch in
der foodszene unterwegs und haben eigene
Lieferservices Restaurants und die will
ich heute mal unter die Lupe nehmen mit
dabei sind massiv mit einem Dönerladen
Aard mit einem Burgerladen den ihr
vielleicht von tiktok kennt und
natürlich Luciano mit LC chicken deshalb
reden wir nicht lange rum und begeben
uns direkt zum ersten Spot und damit
sind wir auch schon vom ersten Laden
hinter mir befindet sich Babas Döner von
Massiv den gibt es sogar einige Male in
Deutschland ich meine ich habe in Berlin
mal ein Laden gesehen wir sind jetzt in
Offenbach denn später geht's noch nach
Frankfurt und hier gibt es einen Döner
den massiv selbst entworfen hat er hat
dieses Design gemacht und Berliner Döner
ist ja so ein Ding ich liebe Berliner
Döner das habe ich glaube ich schon zu
genüge erzählt deshalb bin ich sehr
gespannt wie gut dieser Laden hier
wirklich ist ich glaube das ist
Franchise wir quatschen mal drin mit den
Jungs und lassen uns einen schönen Döner
basteln weil wie kann ein Tag besser
starten als mit einem guten Döner eine
wichtige Frage vorab hallo erm sind das
hier Berliner Soßen alles von
Berlin blau Schar Schar sehr geil das
klingt ging schon mal sehr sehr gut das
sieht doch wirklich gut aus also er
wurde auf jeden Fall mit Liebe gemacht
von den Jungs hier die Spieße sahen
solide aus ich hate das Gefühl dass beim
Abschneiden sah es fast ein bisschen
trocken aus aber ich bin gespannt wie
sich das jetzt im Döner verhält wir
haben zwei Version gemacht beide mit
Schafskäse das sind 50 Cent extra der
Grundpreis sind 6,50 € eric hat noch
Grillgemüse dazu genommen weil er das
noch nie hatte ich finde aber erste
Erscheinungsbild wunderschön der Döner
ist voller als voll ja bei 650 absolut
fair wenn da nicht bisschen kamerabonus
dabei ist das werden wir aber nicht
erfahren weil wir haben natürlich direkt
gefragt ob wir filmen können also Leute
lasst uns einfach mal probieren es sieht
schon wirklich sehr sehr gut aus und
allein diese Knoblauchsoße einfach ein
Traum probieren
wir zu dem Döner wird natürlich auch
Besteck dazu gelegt von Baba Döner bring
seht sogar diese Dönertasche hier hat
das Branding ich sitz neben riesigen
Schild man weiß auf jeden Fall dass das
Döner von Massiv ist und der erste
Bissen ich sag so viel war auf jeden
Fall nicht
schlecht im Vergleich jetzt sage ich
jetzt mal ne zu diesem geheimen Döner
den wir getestet haben den wir ja auch
an diesem Tag unglaublich gefeiert haben
weil er mal ein bisschen leerer war der
ist ja doppelte Portion quasi der ist
wirklich doppelte Portion der geheim
Döner hat 5 € gekostet ich habe mir
gedacht okay fair wenn ich davon zwei
ess Umsatz zu werden zah ich 10 € jetzt
zah ich 7,50 € also es ist auf jeden
Fall im en ich mag gerne ich bin Fan von
dieser ped ne von der klassischen
geviertelten ped die schön im Kontakt
getoastet wird knusprig wird ich mag das
einfach also für mich ist das nicht
unbedingt schlechter als ein Laden der
sein Brot selbst backt außer es es jetzt
fair hat in Wien wo das Brot einfach ein
Gedicht ist ne also so ein normales in
anführungzeich normales selbstgebackenes
dönerbrot ist nicht zwangsläufig besser
als diese ped hier gehen wir mal aufs
Fleisch ein im Einzelnen wenn du es mal
so probierst ich probiere noch mal pro
das
Fleisch es hat einen schönen Geschmack
aber dieses etwas trockene was ich auch
von der Optik bekommen habe spiegelt
sich ein bisschen wieder also der Döner
glänzt nicht über das Fleisch er ist
sehr lecker es ist auch trotzdem schön
fettig ne also es ist es ist echt ein
leckeres Fleisch aber ich habe schon
besseres Dönerfleisch gehabt sagen wir
so wir haben ja selbst gerade
festgestellt dass am Ende nicht noch mal
so eine Kelle Soße oben drauf gegeben
wurde vermisst man nicht unbedingt der
Döner ist auf jeden Fall saftig genug
mit dem Gemüse mit dem Käse und die Soße
wurde halt im Brot auf beiden Seiten
auch ausgestren S dass man schon
trotzdem bei jedem Beit genug Soße dabei
hat aber es auf jeden Fall interessanter
Ansatz wir haben auch was ein bisschen
untypisch ist Mais drin wir haben alles
ganz klassisch bestellt Mais mit dabei
kenne ich so nicht besonders ist nicht
weit verbreitet sage ich mal aus Döner
aber trotzdem finde ich es geil einen
Punkt habe ich allerdings noch und der
betrifft die Soße mh auch wenn die da
ist ne auch wenn du sie schmeckst es ist
nicht die Berliner Soße die ich liebe
Knoblauchsoße bestellt hab mich unnormal
gefreut auf diese süßliche Knoblauchsoße
die geht eher so ein bisschen ins
würzige also klar knoblauch ist immer
würzig aber der ist nicht so süßwürzig
sondern vor allem würzig es ist nicht
das was ich mir gewünscht habe aber es
ist trotzdem insgesamt ein echt guter
Döner also kannst dir nichts sagen
gerade so wie wir den bekommen haben
Pril gefüllt mit Liebe gemacht also
vollkommen im Rahmen und
überdurchschnittlich gut wenn du es
vergleichst mit anderen döneren eric ist
der Experte für kaiöner sagt euch mal
seine fachmännische Meinung dazu guck
dir mal an alter das aber fällt schon
wieder auf
Tisch das Brot ist übertrieben geil
probier mal hier dein kalfleisch
ähnlichche Sache finde ich ne also der
der Döner besticht nicht durch sein
Fleisch und ich finde das ist da das ist
das woran die richtig guten Döner
erkennst wenn die ein krassen Spieß
haben ja Freunde Döner ist aufgegessen
und guckt euch das mal bitte an man
kriegt dieses kleine Paket hier da drin
ist einfach das ist geil ein Zahnstocher
auch wenn man nichts zwischen den Zehnen
hat kann man einfach schön diesen hier
machen hat er nicht sogar in der Serie
voll auf diesen Zahnstocher auch glaube
ich häufig Zahnstocher ja und was auch
krass ist Branding hört nicht auf wir
haben h eine Serviette drin und das ist
uns gerade aufgefallen die parfümiert
ist die duftet einfach nach was hat das
Marketingteam auf allen Sinnen
gearbeitet Marketing ist auf jeden Fall
durchgespielt auch hier noch ein
gebrandetes Erfrischungstuch und so und
das zieht sich finde ich ein bisschen
durch den Laden weil wenn du das hast
und ein krassen Döner vorbei ich würde
sagen wir sind in of gewesen ab nach
FFM war irgendwie salzig oder ich war
schon so lange nicht mehr high nicht
hydrated vielen Dank an er den Sponsor
des heutigen Videos ker Spaß Freunde
natürlich war ich vor kurzem noch
hydrated ja wir sind gerade auf dem Weg
nach Frankfurt zu unserem nächsten Spot
und zwar zu bossburger der Laden von AAT
den aber ganz viele von euch mit
Sicherheit auch von tiktok kennen und
ich muss einfach sagen an Tagen wie
diesen wo wir viel unterwegs sind viel
essen vergisst man häufig das Trinken
deshalb habe ich meine steelbottte von
Air natürlich immer dabei das beste ist
ja am Ende des Tages ist hier drin
einfach Wasser ich trinke Wasser aber es
schmeckt immer nach genau dem was ich
möchte jetzt gerade habe ich kassis
drauf das heißt schme schmeckt schön
nach diesen klassischen Bonbons so ein
bisschen aber ich kann mir auch guava
drauf hauen Limette ich kann unterm
Strich nur sagen dass ich wirklich mehr
trinke mit er weil das ist fast schon
wie eine kleine Gewohnheit so wenn man
die Flasche hat es macht einfach auch
Spaß daran zu trinken man nuckelt immer
so ein bisschen daran rum ist gesund
deshalb kann ich wirklich wärmstens
empfehlen und nicht ohne Grund bin ich
ja auch schon seit Januar diesen Jahres
Partner bei er stehe ich voll dahinter
ist eine super Sache und Fall ihr
Probleme mit dem Trinken habt dann
checkt er ab ab wie ich immer so gerne
sage wir checken jetzt bossburger ab und
ich bin sehr gespannt ob der Laden
ansatzweise so gut ist wie auf tiktok
aussieht ich könn mir vorstellen dass es
manche einer nicht weiß dieser
Burgerladen hinter mir ist von azard
aber der ein oder andere von euch wird
ihn vielleicht von tiktok kennen denn es
gibt den legendären Koch hier Anil heißt
der und er ist bekannt für die Videos
ver sagt kommt einfach mal rein ich zeig
euch und genauso wurden wir gerade kurz
empfangen als wir gefragt haben ob wir
bisschen filmen können unfassbar nett
aber es geht hier nicht um
Freundlichkeit das ist kein
freundlichkeitswettbewerb sondern wir
schauen wie gut auch dieses Restaurant
von asard ist auf tiktok sieht das schon
verdammt gut aus die haben eine saubere
Küche die sind begeistert von Ihrem
Produkt und ich bin gespannt wie gut es
heute performt ich würde sagen wir gehen
mal rein und schauen wie gut die
bossbger wirklich sind wie lange macht
ihr tiktok jetzt wir sind jetzt seit d
Monaten D Monaten gefühlt kenne ich an
schon länger als mein eigenen Vater ich
habe schon so oft gesehen auf tiktok
Geist ja Familienbetrieb ja ich bin
morgens da der kommt abends aber sehr
sehr super gut so einen Sohn zu haben da
muss stolz
sein er macht das richtig gut ich weiß
wirklich nicht ob ich hier gerade von
ein Rapper laden oder von dem tiktok
Laden Sitze weil irgendwie beides ohne
disrespectt das ist so krass ich find so
gut was die auf tiktok machen und klar
das ist auch der Laden von ASAT aber es
ist auch irgendwie der tiktok Laden ich
probiere zu allererst einm die
hausgemachten Nuggets 100% Hähnchen
Brustfleisch wir haben gefragt besser
als McDonald's jetzt wo ich die sehe
glaube schon dass sie besser als
McDonald's sind probieren wir schön mit
ananassoße alle Soßen Haus gemacht ihr
wisst Bescheid let's
go ich fin chicken mcnugget ist so eine
Beleidigung dafür das sind filetbites so
weiß wie ich meine das sind keine
Chicken McNuggets vor allen Dingen nicht
mcnuggetsick irgendwie schon also der
Begriff wurde nur beschädigt von
McDonald's andererseits wir wissen ja
alle auch ich ich liebe ja diese Chicken
McNuggets ne aber das ist ein anderes
Produkt das ist irgendwie man merkt das
ist viel hochwertiger wenn das hier die
normale Portion ist Respekt und ich hab
ja gesehen guck mal das Ding ist ein Tag
vorher legen die das Hähnchen ein dann
nachdem es eingelegt wurde am Tag sel
vor dem in die Friteuse legen einmal in
die Panade rein direkt in die Friteuse
also frisch paniert in die Friteuse rein
und das ist halt das Ergebnis ne das
werden wir bei unserem letzten Spot noch
anders sehen ne LCO chicken ist
vorpaniert deshalb bin ich unfassbar
gespannt wie lo chicken performen wird
selbst KFC paniert ja im Laden selbst
KFC paniert im Laden und KFC ist ja so
ein bisschen die Benchmark finde ich ne
weil das auch Kette das ist auch
Systemgastronomie wird spannend aber
erstmal muss ich sagen dass das hier auf
jeden Fall besser als jedes Standard
Fastfood chicken ist das ist richtig
lecker hier mit
Harissa der Crunch die
Schärfe und dieser Burger hier ist zu
wild denkt euch wahrscheinlich du hast
noch gar nicht gebissen ja er heißt aber
zu wild Burger nimm den mal so in die
Hand Geis sieht wirklich wunderschön
fotogen aus ne also keine Frage man
sieht auch richtig du siehst hier unten
diese Kruste die kommt wenn du so ein so
ein Brot mit Ei bestreichst bevor du es
backst also das ist wirklich kein
industriell gefertigtes Brot frisch
gebacken von der Bäckerei halumi auch
hier eine sehr schöne groe weiß nicht ob
der frittiert oder gebraten wird der
wird auch auf der planscher mitgebraten
ja rinderbacon schöne Käsesoße hier und
auch sehr smart so mäßig das Salatblatt
eingesetzt damit das nicht durchsifft
und so ne also dass der Burger trotzdem
noch ja in seiner Konsistenz bleibt
gucken wir ob der Burger wirklich zu
wild ist der kostet ein Zehner ja keine
Frage aber das hat auch überhaupt gar
nichts zu tun mit dem Fastfood Burger
also da ist ja alles dran Haus und
selbstgemacht alter Schwede das kann
sich sehen lassen soßig saftig sieht aus
jetzt bin ich sehr gespannt was du sagst
Leute das probieren wir jetzt mal wenn
ich schaffe das irgendwie zu essen rein
da boah
Abbruch kurz bisschen rinderbaken im
Hals gehabt alles super wirklich gerade
das erste Mal reingbiss erste Mal
reingebissen die Nuggets wow nicht zu
viel versprochen kein Vergleich zu
Nuggets ist das krasseste was es gibt
Nug ist also eigentlich generell ich
will jetzt nicht über mein Produkt loben
ja was wir machen das macht keiner einf
glaube ich gerne und das in so einem
kleinen Laden also Respekt dafür glau
Samstag vi los ist jetzt kommt gerade
Winter bisschen eng Sommer das war
rappen und draußen wir sind wirklich
nicht dazuekommen mit zum Produzieren
sehr schön aber gotz se dan wie lange
Laden läuft wir s zufrieden Dings
Handschuhe nein alles gut he sind eh
schon dreckig super wir haben gerade
Youtube Video gedreht dein Papa ist
genau n wie du mein Vater ist cool seh
Co krass ja der weiß auch nicht wer ich
bin glaube ich auch sich die Zeit
genommen hat erzählt man fühlt sich sehr
sehr wohl hier als Gast also es ist auf
jeden Fall eine wilde Kreation man merkt
hier hier ist jemand am Werke die Karte
hat jemand gemacht der Lust hat auf
Burger der Lust hat zu kochen auf
Kreation das ist kein Standard das ist
kein Chili Cheese das ist kein cheese
das kein kein Barbecue Bacon das ist
halt was Eigenes ne und die Kreation
funktioniert sehrut gut sehr schön
salzig mit den hallumi mit dem
rinderbacon kein Stück trocken weil ihr
habt die Soßen gesehen die sind überall
also nach dem ersten Bissen würde ich
fast schon sagen dass wenn jemand einen
Laden aufmacht dann soll es so sein
Freunde wirklich unfassbar sympathisch
also genau genau wie im Internet ich
möchte eine Sache kurz hier loswerden an
der Stelle ist keine Kooperation ich
muss gerade noch mal die Website
nachschauen ein Kumpel von mir der KAL
üris der gasthoflüer kennt ihr
vielleicht von hallo meine Lieben
gastkollegen hat eine Aktion in die Welt
gerufen weil gerade hat mich noch mal
richtig gepackt wie geil so diese
Gastronomie ist der brennt für sein
Laden der lebt dafür das Ding ist nach
der coronazeit wurde die Mehrwertsteuer
in der Gastronomie von 19% auf 7 %
gesenkt damit quasi den Gastronomen
bisschen geholfen wird und damals wurde
gesagt ey überhaupt kein Problem bleibt
für immer so 7 % bleiben das hat sogar
Olaf Scholz selbst gesagt jetzt steht
ins Haus dass die Mehrwertsteuer von 7 %
wieder auf 19 % hochgen soll das heißt
nichts anderes als dass alles in
Restaurants 12 % teurer wird so und das
ist für uns scheiße das ist für
Gastronomen scheiße und viele
Gastronomen stecken immer noch wirklich
in Problemen aus der coronazeit deshalb
check mal bitte den Link unten in der
Beschreibung ab da ist eine Petition
verlinkt da könnt ihr gerne
unterschreiben weil ich glaube das ist
eine Sache die sollte man auf jeden Fall
supporten weil so sowas hier so eine
Gastronomie das ist einfach geil das ist
für jeden Gast dort eine Bereicherung
und das wäre scheiße wenn die jetzt noch
weiter belastet werden deshalb keine
Werbung oder so sondern eine vernünftige
Sache wir fahren jetzt zurück nach Köln
so Freunde wir sind auf dem Rückweg nach
Köln und hier drüben seht ihr jetzt das
worauf ich so lange gewartet habe Eric
wie er trinkt nein Spaß das sieh man am
Rand Loc chicken Südstadt ohne Witz ich
musste mich so zusammenreißen nicht
schon die ganzen Videos zu loco chicken
zu gucken ich weiß gar nicht mal so
richtig was das loco chicken Angebot ist
und jetzt gucken wir mal gemeinsam rein
also wir sehen auf jeden Fall schon dass
hier eine krasse Vielfalt ist large loco
Mix big loco Brownie ohne Witz das sind
ja richtig richtig viele Items Items s
ich auch schon aber das sind richtig
viele Produkte das hätte ich gar nicht
gedacht dass das so umfangreich ist wir
machen jetzt mal ein warnkorb voll wir
bestellen übrigens jetzt schon aus dem
Auto weil wir gehört haben dass es sehr
lange dauern kann und hier ist alles
worauf wir gewartet haben loco chicken
ist endlich angekommen bzw das war
eigentlich also ist perfekt pünktlich
angekommen das kan gerade falsch aber
ich habe es endlich vor mir stehen das
wollte ich eigentlich sagen und wir
schauen einfach mal rein ich glaub keine
andere Tüte wurde in den letzten Tagen
in food Youtube Deutschland mehr gesehen
das stimmt allerdings geil dass sie auch
ihre eigene liefertüte haben ja
ich se schon bring auf jeden Fall ist
dreimal die gleiche Soße haben die
Auswahl nicht mehr dann haben die mir
ich glaube die haben die Auswahl nicht
mehr hab mir einfach paar Mal die
gleiche gegeben weil die sieh die sieht
genauso aus wie die oder se und das hier
ist vierm
die GE dann könnte man ja auch einfach
das Produkt offline stellen ne also oder
ich i Unrecht getan das sind auch alles
Soßen ja das sind auch Soßen rosaryy
Ketchup Hot Chili Sauce hot chili ich
glaub ich das hier sind
ich werde der F mit den crispy Fries
anfangen denn sie sind ja angeblich so
crispy und das machen wir jetzt ich
glaube ich muss gar nichts sagen sondern
ihr müsst einfach nur hören ob sie noch
crispy
sind hab jetzt Air Video okay diese
Pommes haben jedes Recht sich crispy
Fries zu nennen weil die sind wirklich
auch nach dem liefern merklich
knuspriger als normale Pommes ich denke
dass Luciano auf jeden Fall diese
Authentizität se
das real americ und das gibt mir auf
jeden Fall den Eindruck das ist wirklich
so eine geile überzüchtete Barbecue die
so auch diese Essig diese Essigsäure da
drin die du absolut in deiner Nase schon
schmecken kannst hier haben wir unsere
truffle waffle lieferkonzept ist geil
muss ich sagen also auch hier dass die
Pommes quasi Luft bekommen so werden sie
halt eben auch nicht so trocken aber
schneller kalt kalt sind stimmt hat so
ein bisschen was von diesem Quark von
diesem Teigstückchen auf dem
weihnachtsmarkto auch einfach so Käse
drüber gegeben wird das sieht schon
weniger geil aus wenig appetitlich aus S
ich ganz ehrlich Präsentation ist
wirklich nicht besonders gut und drunter
ist so eine klassische belgische Waffel
glaube ich wie man die auch fertig
kaufen kann ich fühle auch nicht white
truffle jetzt mit so einer Waffel gesm
Auer der Reim
TR ich
probiere ich habe jetzt gerade aus
Versehen direkt schon das Chicken
probiert probier mal
pur das ist ja schon irendwie das
Herzstück ne bevor du was sagst probier
erstmal die Wings noch probieren wir
jetzt endlich mal den garlic cheese Wing
jede Menge Panade außenrum loco chicken
sollte auf jeden Fall ein sehr sehr sehr
sehr gutes chicken abliefern probieren
wir das knuspert auf jeden Fall schwer
dazu eine Meinung zu bilden finde ich
das Ding ist auf den ersten Blick ne ist
das 100% mein Ding American Sau so geile
spieleereien wie diese dry rubs oder
halt diese diese Würz diese
trockenwürzung richtig geil ich finde
dass man die dass es zu viel Panade ist
Panade weißt du da ist so viel Panade
dran ich glaube es zieht sich etwas
durch die Spots das geile daran ist
nicht das Fleisch wenn du so ein Bit
hast ne wo richtig Panade drauf ist dann
wirkt das noch mal ganz anders dann isst
du nämlich gefühlt nicht mehr ein
chicken Wing dann isst du so ein Nacho
cheese dorito die ade ich frage mich die
ganze Zeit was das ist das ist ja nicht
nur Mehl eine Sache ist klar große Props
an jeden der heute dabei war dafür dass
er sowas auf die Beine gestellt hat
eigenes Restaurant ist einfach nice also
Props dafür ich habe auf jeden Fall
probiert euch zu zeigen wie ich es fand
und was vielleicht noch besser geht
falls euch das Video gefallen hat dann
lasst gerne ein Like da ein komm ein Abo
und ich küsse eure Ärsche no
sexual